I think we all freaked out a little bit
when we saw Oprah at Harry and Megan's
wedding well lady Oh looking royal
stunning like a queen herself on the
cover of British Vogue and she tells the
magazine she freaked out for an entirely
different reason we had dress ski
[Music]
Oprah's pink Stella McCartney creation
was the last-minute change because she
thought her original cream-colored dress
photographed too white she says I
googled can you wear white to a wedding
answer no don't risk it nice to know
even Oprah doesn't always have all the
answers the 64 year old mogul tells all
in the August issue of British Vogue one
cover even features her in a racy black
lace mask she also explains why she will
never run for president quote all the
nine truths the nastiness the backhanded
backroom stuff that goes on I feel like
I could not exist it's not a clean
business
if we kill me funny that's pretty much
what she told us last year how'd that
happen that is just not gonna happen
oh yeah just cuz that would not be my
strength my strength is bringing people
together